[Music]
what's up you guys Denny here welcome to
the daily Danny live we got your live
official Emmys recap talking about what
you didn't see on TV and of course all
the fashion but I can't do it by myself
I need help and that's why I have my
beautiful co-host Katie Krauss equally
as beautiful our et senior style editor
Marissa Runyon good morning guys we're
jacked up on coffee so Jenna here last
night watching the Emmy Awards which is
interesting because I'm gonna say I
thought they were snoozefest you know
but they were so much hope there was a
lot of hope Newsies I was just like okay
let's move it along
ah but thankfully as Marissa pointed out
earlier this morning it was on fire
though gold carpets that celebrate the
70th Emmys we do want to know what you
guys thought who your favorite dress
favorite moments of the night let us
know in the comments section below we
are gonna get to the fun moments of the
Emmys though before we get into the
fashion beginning with what everybody is
still talking about that surprise
proposal that was the highlight of the
night really was me I was getting food
no lie like my second helping in mac and
cheese catering and everyone was running
over the TVs to watch what was happening
because it was so unexpected what a
glorious surprise was such a moment of
love and and just really unexpected I'm
so glad they didn't cut him off I think
he made a call out to the director of
the Emmys the director of the Oscars so
I bet he knows the director of the Emmys
pretty well and he said hamish give me a
minute exactly if you hear it I knew the
director but yeah let's set it up for
you guys in case you missed it Glenn
Weiss is the director of the Oscars he
had just won the Emmy for directing a
variety special when he took the moment
on stage to surprise his girlfriend and
propose we have a clip for you guys yeah
take a look you wonder why I don't like
to call you my girlfriend because I want
to call you my wife
[Applause]
everybody lost their crying honest and
just really lovely like what if he did
not win what was the plan then
interesting Allah interestingly enough
we did talk to him backstage
et's Kevin Frazier and Kel teen I talked
to the a newly engaged couple backstage
he said there wasn't a plan B their life
is plan a he said it would have happened
somewhere else
every wasn't the stage it was somewhere
else but he's glad he could pull it off
on one of the world's biggest stages in
front of that crowd I mean Leslie Jones
during that clip you could see it just
like freaking out like that was all of
us but again we got to Glenn and his new
fiance backstage who watch back the
moment and relived the surprise proposal
my mind here what absolutely blew my
mind here was the reaction that not your
reaction the room reaction honest to God
when I thought of doing this and in my
head I'm thinking oh they're gonna play
me off nobody's gonna want me to be
doing this I really had all that you
know going out of my head
like what if they don't and then all of
a sudden I couldn't even finish what I
had planned because everybody was on
their feet and yelling and screaming
which was great I'm sorry I didn't I
didn't even notice that anybody to this
moment I have to watch it but I didn't
realize that people were standing and
clapping because I literally just saw
you and I just was so like I'm talking
to you I mean way to steal the show and
such a great way to everybody loves
everybody wants that moment of happiness
that moment that grounds it the moment
that you are you remember that memorable
moment that's what was missing from the
night's host Michael Chen Colin Jost you
know I couldn't tell you one joke of
theirs but that proposal all the hosts
would have disappeared after that thank
God
opening I'm glad they go no I'm glad
they do and I love that they weren't in
that opening number I think that was the
best part about yeah I'm sorry I just
did not get into Michael you disagree
let me know right exactly another moment
everybody's talking about that you might
have almost missed last night during the
telecast was Donald Glover as his really
creepy character from Atlanta Teddy
Perkins in the audience right exactly
this was around the time this is
look at that bill hader just beat Donald
it for Outstanding Lead Actor in a
comedy series a lot of people are trying
to figure out was that actually Donald
because later in the show not long long
after we see Donald and a fool Gucci
tux looking like normal you know and in
fact a lot of people were like is it him
was it his co-star lucky Stanfield well
a source tells ET that the man behind
the disguise was SNL's Jay Pharoah Jay
Pharoah has told us Jay was in costume
which makes sense because later at the
after parties which we'll get into later
you could there's pictures of Donald and
likitha posing together with Teddy
Perkins know at first saying who's that
in the front row who is that because
actually when Bill Hader wine he went
and shook his hand
Teddy's hands yeah I missed it too
wasn't it to us popping up all over my
rows like oh my god dad oh it was
amazing amazing stunts I imagine that if
Donald woulda won Teddy was gonna accept
the trophy on his behalf so that's the
speech you know another popular group of
people last night were the queer I cast
you know favorite fellas I mean look at
these looks right I want you should you
know every loved that care where amazing
the capes the tails the waistcoats the
little print on tan my boy Antony like
so sharp oh yes I mean they really shook
up the red carpet but inside guys I mean
et was all over the Emmys on the red
carpet inside the Awards at the after
parties here in the office but inside we
were told that the queer eye cast were
the most popular of the night they
walked with the biggest entourage and
were bombarded by fans take asking for
selfies I'm not surprised by this I was
actually at a pre MEP Artie and I was
talking to Bobby Burk and he said
Jennifer Aniston came up to him quote
googly eyed are you kidding at one of
the preeminent Aniston is approaching
you he said Tina Fey Jason Bateman like
celebrities are also just as obsessed
with these guys listen as everyone else
I mean they're irresistible the show is
resistible I mean I'm not surprised and
I love that they're actually stopping
and taking these pictures interact with
all people they're a fanboying out too
with all these celebrities it's a really
awesome moment for that whole night was
very overwhelmingly positive like
everybody was dressed in a happy
beautiful way and with the proposal it
was just a lot of love and happiness
speaking of love it was also a really
beautiful couples night on the red
carpet and we want to point out Heidi
Klum and her man Oh
Col it's like they have not hit a red
carpet together until now and they're
just looking oh so adorable right there
oh look they were so in love I love when
couples are on the red carpet and
constantly looking at each other about
the PDA it's like thank you for that we
did that yeah I get the sense I'd Tom
would not let go of Heidi's hand I mean
she was also taking selfies with fans
interact with a lot of people but he
held on to the entire time yeah I'm sure
it's kind of overwhelming for him but
also I just think it's right like this
is my woman and I love her ya know but
yeah it was awesome couples night which
gets us right into the fashion recap
guys on the red carpet because we have
to start with Scarlett Johansson yeah
yeah she I don't know what she's been
doing but she looks amazing
yeah she's turning out to show their
support for calling Joseph Austin this
to me is like my man is hosting the
award shows and I'm gonna show up and
knock them dead yeah it's flawless a
hair orgy neckline I don't know if
that's her natural skin tone or she got
like a little glow but I mean she's
radiates yes like that gold carpet is
just like bouncing off of her and she
looks awesome she's wearing custom
bowmen and like giving me everything and
just that white sequined situation you
can barely tell it's sequined until you
catch a great close-up shot and it's the
tiniest sequences so the texture is
perfect and it fit her body me I mean
come on I mean way to like slay on the
red carpet cuz we didn't see her after
that you know she's probably the stage
Breeden's here in the crowd I mean she
that was a moment for her and Colin the
best thing about the night were calling
was that he showed up with Scarlett
he did all equally as good I mean I've
always been a big fan of his hair sure
cuts on point
yes cute adorable he's adorable and like
the two of them together I mean stunning
everything about her look was amazing if
you played Cory with those two yes will
you bring in he's like oh all right
Katie one of your favorite this is my
absolute best dressed of the night it is
Jessica Biel she's in Ralph Andrew so
it's this creamy dreamy white it's
almost like cascading it's a sheer
bodice and I mean when you have Justin
Timberlake to stand next to it like you
really can go wrong but usually I know
this is an unpopular opinion I have not
a lot of hope and Jessica Biel's on the
red carpet I don't think she always
brings it up to me this is her best look
she's ever worn I love that she left her
hair down those loose romantic beachy
waves I just think this was a 10 out of
10 please with you I thought her lip
color was perfect her hair look and her
skin was glowing and effortless and you
know this is a gown that's right off the
runway this is Ralph and Russo Wow oh
yeah right off the runway and she just
slipped into it looking like a
perfection dream it's like it made for
her - it's her first Emmy nomination her
husband JT's their support I mean she
wanted it to be just as special as it
felt you know and she looked at you know
a lot of people did not like the look or
some I should say some people didn't
like the look I saw people on Twitter
comparing it to the paper plate no I
totally agree hands-down best dress and
I think it was Tiffany Haddish who said
that she wants to rip that dress off her
body get married in it right seriously
no oh now moving on to another look that
was a little divisive I think there was
a people who appreciated it and some
people who did it and that's Tracee
Ellis Ross all right turned it out I'm
gonna take this one because she she's
just like my red carpet style maven she
can wear anything and pull it off and
the thing with this dress look at her
she's so cool
she's what I love about her she takes
risks she doesn't care what other people
think and she can pull off these in
amazing silhouettes I don't know who
else could pull off this dress maybe
rihanna me that we all honey that you
say this so she's wearing Valentino but
it's very reminiscent of the Grammy
dress that Rihanna wear wore yeah a
couple of years ago this valley like yes
10t dress the only thing that was I
liked Rihanna's look a little bit better
this to me I get what she's going for
and the only person who I think could
pull this off is Tracee Ellis Ross
oversized and like dramatic and amazing
and that's why I appreciate it I get
where you're coming from but at the end
of the day it's like thank you for
showing up in a bold color yes we're
taking a risk I mean and her eye makeup
to match it right and like that's it's
couture its high-fashion it's not
something you're supposed to see on the
streets you know it supposed to be
something that stands out like that and
and she's that's exactly what happened
she stood out I mean how hard is that to
walk in do you think I feel like it's
probably really comfortable he's not
slammed into a super tight dress this is
a comfy looking look at this she's
nothing she could take a nap on it later
at that yeah yeah she is trying to get
that texture if there's not an occasion
for couture when is there yeah thank you
right thank you for bringing some fun
I see Farrah here saying she loved
Tracy's dress like all the dresses cuz I
don't like this next one alright so this
is the thing she's wearing a custom
proble Garonne and he made this dress
for her with the colors of her father's
home country flag and I like that it has
meaning behind I love that as meaning
it's I'm not a fan though right I mean
she even told us when we talked to her
on the red carpet that she's like I'm
serving you a little hot dog on the
stick he knows she knows yeah I'm not
into it I think it's the colors were
really bold but side by side I just feel
like it cheapens it a little bit but it
just it didn't do it for me and the
silhouette seemed kind of simple you
know what I reminded me of those big
parachutes
or Jim that you were running over I mean
people between about it's the same
pattern
it's the same the colors were the same
order Bravo come on problem I mean
literally at the eye I thought about
like you know fire drills when they try
to keep you occupied like on the lawn
and you like run under the parachutes
like thanks for bringing back my job
Tiffany how's jack oh I love the tribute
boy wasn't a fan of the dress I just
feel like if anyone could pull this off
and have fun with it it is Tiffany
Haddish kind of like how you guys feel
about Tracee Ellis Ross not that I love
the dress but I love Tiffany so much I'm
like girlfriend can do no wrong in my
book and I think you guys should take a
look at what she had to say about the
dress Kevin Frazier last night tell me
about this dress so this is dresses by
proper Quran and it's custom made it's
the only one that exists because I asked
them to make a dress that represents
Eritrea my mother's country it's these
are the same colors as the flag from
Eritrea it has meaning no manners right
look we should also wore dress which was
a tribute to her father's country at the
Oscars - I dress again okay for the
third time I gotta say though Tiffany
did turn up though she always has the
best time at these things in fact we are
told that eyewitness told us that at the
Netflix party she was seen twerking up
on Dave Chappelle - Drake's music in my
feelings how can you not talk to those
plug you know and like I'm sure Dave was
into it
apparently the Netflix party was the
place to be because by the way benedict
cumberbatch bach batch with uh he was
spotted dancing to cardi B yeah okay so
they were turn up at that party you guys
so one who turned up in fashion
oh really Bobby brother princess of
fashion Bobby Brown she's 14 years old
you guys if I looked this put together
now I'd be proud like 14 forget it I was
a hot mess she is in this perfect
perfect beautiful Calvin Klein dress
made for her matching shoes and it's
just age-appropriate and fresh and
lovely and she looked horrible he's
perfect
- and I love the silhouette I love the
princess look we actually talked to
Milly on the red carpet and answered it
last night take a look right yes just
are you a New York Fashion Week is that
where you found your dress yeah we had a
fitting there actually yeah so yeah yeah
well we got the sketch about two months
ago and it took two months nearly two
months to make this beautiful dress and
there yeah no but it's been we are
definitely a rollercoaster with finding
what I like and what I how long I want
it and how tight you know it's it's yeah
it's beautiful though I love it I like
how much input she has in her fashion
for being so young it sounds like she's
very involved in the process it took two
months to find that she says it was a
roller coaster to find what she likes
she looks like a cupcake dream and it
you know it's so it's so tricky for
teenagers especially really young teen
Hollywood not to go the total opposite
way if she had her say and she was like
most 14 year olds would be a very
different look but she's going with
something that's so age-appropriate and
so elegant and I just I love I love her
message I love everything about her
she's a great role model she says she's
finding her way in style and fashion and
find out what she likes and doesn't like
but so far she's pretty much nailing it
I love it anywhere look - but she turns
it out on a red carpet one of my
favorite looks of the night came
courtesy of Mandy Moore in custom
Rodarte I mean come on Oh Mandy and it
was a hot day you know yesterday I feel
like this is probably perfect for the
weather yeah you know like and it's
complements for dark hair right now I'm
just like so into this or whole makeup
look and everything Beach waves were
where it was at everyone had their hair
loose nobody looked too stuffy or too
fussy I love this like casual hair look
on her and I love the length of this
journey didn't hit the floor it showed
you her shoes it was really interesting
right almost like a mermaid look at the
end wait but I love that it didn't raise
before was something different yeah a
neckline Mandy why it's sexy but also
very chic and appropriate for the Emmys
you know I mean wasn't too much it was
just the right amount of sexy you know
oh so good slayed that moving right
along to Issa Rae in custom beer away
this is what I loved about last night
there were a lot of women rocking suits
and she has this great hybrid which is
this beautiful jumpsuit with kind of
this open over skirt train situation
newly elegant and beautiful custom Vera
Wang so fun fact about this dress it
took a hundred hours to make this
amazing detailing on that it's like this
baby blue it's frosty she kind of looks
like a 20-18 modern Cinderella does a
lot of ways she does I loved what she
told us how she felt in it too you guys
take a look at what she said to Kevin
last night feel tell me about this
outfit cuz it's a pantsuit but a dress
it kind of flows it doesn't my dress
last year and this year she hugged me
I'm oh I'm wearing I'm expensive someone
said I look expensive but I was like
nobody's ever told me that before you do
look it look like you look expect like
you looked at Westside you know money
that's who you look like
not Westside LA Westlife Manhattan that
way yeah and them in one of those
buildings knows if you were a jumpsuit
out at night you have to like unzip and
then if it's a high zip you're like you
need a buddy to help me real quick I
wasn't the biggest fan of this look I
didn't like I didn't like the color I
thought it just was a little but the I
don't think was proportionate enough for
me either
like I just would you all right if it
was in a darker color yes yes yes I
almost feel like a darker blue because
none even the pants it's like if that
was a dress I still wouldn't be a family
I was just felt to prom yeah prom but I
do love that the girls feel inexpensive
because she earned it I mean that web
series from YouTube is now that an HBO
hit and she's nominated for a first
exactly right one of your favorites
birthday that sandy Newland this was one
of my favorites so we were just in New
York for New York Fashion Week and this
gown walked the runway and she literally
plucked it off Gigio deeds body award to
the NBA this is Brandon Maxwell it's
just a stunning stunning shade of pink
and I shook swallows yeah
amazing he looked at me so I was engaged
when she accepted her yeah there is the
dress right off the runway right off the
runway which means
10-newton girl you are supermodel right
this dress looks flawless on both women
right speaks volumes about how amazingly
it's put together that just exactly the
silhouette is beautiful I love that like
scarfy train situation oh your neck
she looks beautiful and this Center
parted hair had was kind of like the
theme of the night whether it was up or
down so great she nailed it the look was
perfect for that like swept like you
said that scarf like yak situation like
she looks so elegant and dramatic oh I
love it
everyone worked color I'm so happy yes
because of course last year was in the
in the in light of me too and time's up
everyone kind of toned it down and wore
black or most people were black at least
see bright colors come back I was
excited
usually you see those at the VMAs so I
was like yes and these yeah you know we
have talked about some of the guys
course we're as favorite dressing the
entire cast of strangers they were all
on point
hmm forget about boring tuxedos they've
took like every fashion risk in the book
and they're young and they're cool and
they completely pulled it off I mean
it's not just Millie Bobby Brown it's
literally the entire cast that always
shows up to slay and I'm just so beyond
impressed I mean he's here Sharky did
fun absolutely and chic that's getting
Matarazzo and I want to steal that Jack
actually you would look great yellow
Dolce and Gabbana yes the bowtie kills
me and the hair go adorable because of
course it's set in Haiti so they got a
rock to it but I love it speaking of
joke Yuri yeah also in Dolce & Gabbana
in Dolce and also with the the massive
80s hair here is that it's a mullet can
we to be considered ah it's borderline
it's getting there you know what I'm not
mad at it know why I lighted it's kind
of them all it's kind of wallet the
color is perfect his girlfriend
mieka monroe who is also stunning oh
yeah the stranger the stranger things
cast really turned it out and in fact I
see Izzy Sophie saying Millie Bobbie
Brown is a queen she's so inspiring and
I love
can't wait for season I cannot wait for
season 3 really excited where is it it's
like when the kicking - it does when the
cashier when the cast is events like
this it's like they're tired of the the
dirt of being on the set of stranger
things I'm ready to like really turn it
out be sheep yeah and just so fashion
forward and I think they are killing it
yeah they're killing it well guys our
final look final look oh my gosh already
an Emmy winner oh this is Oscar de la
Renta it is absolutely gorgeous it's so
romantic
what a night she had what a night
marvelous mrs. Basel had this to me
screams Emmy winner Emmy nominee I can't
get over it she looked at that emoji the
red lady she really does and I love that
it's an interesting twist on a red gown
it's a asymmetrical sleeves and it has
sort of a dip dyed skirt so it gets
deeper deeper red as you go down to the
bottom that's her boyfriend by the way
Jason Ralph yeah there's that part again
you're talking about the it's not quite
Center but it's like everyone's hairs go
back great parts whether it's down the
middle with beach waves or flipped back
that was really the theme of the night
when it comes to beauty also a lot of
fun on pop of color on the lips yes yes
thank you for you think the stars of the
Emmys red carpet for making it exciting
because like I said now this [ __ ] it was
exciting to see who was gonna win just
to see what they were wearing you know
to me as well so thank you for that guys
we're just scratching the surface it's
so hard to take best dress at the Emmys
and on these red carpets but you guys
can head over ET style or et online.com
for a full fashion breakdown plenty of
goodies over there thank you guys so
much for joining me I mean until the
next award show all right guys we'll be
I'll be back tomorrow with another daily
Deni until then make sure you guys head
over ET online.com for all things Emmys
and of course tune in to Entertainment
Tonight
we got a full breakdown to the fashion
the after-party is what you didn't see
on TV and a whole lot more so make sure
you guys tune in alright have a good day
thank you
[Music]